- What is your favorite sex position?
(laughs)
(jazzy piano music)
- We're gonna play the newlywed game!
The way it works is one
person answers a series of
relationship questions, and then
the other person tries
to guess their answers.
It's gonna be fun, let's do it!
Excuse me, are you guys dating?
- No, we're best friends.
- No, you're best friends,
you're not dating. Ok, cool.
Are you guys dating by chance?
- [Both men] No.
- No? Ok.
You guys want to answer some
questions about relationships?
- Sure.
- What is your favorite sex position?
- My parents are here.
I don't think I can answer this question.
- Looking in each other's
eyes. Romantic stuff.
- Around her knees.
- Yeah, definitely doggy style.
- Uh, doggy style.
(snickers)
That's Ellis, bring Amanda back.
Come on back, Michelle!
What is his favorite sex position?
- Sex position?
- Oh I think he's pushing me further away.
- Oh, on top. He likes to be on top.
- I don't know.
- Um, I guess, what, I don't know.
Missionary?
- Doggy?
- Doggy style?
- On top, babe?
(laughs)
- Come on, you know.
- Doggy style? I don't know.
- Is that right?
- I like everything, but
that's not what I answered.
- Is that correct?
- Uh, it's one of my many favorite ones,
but not the one I vote.
- Doggy style.
- Oh God.
- Romance, look in each other's eyes.
- Aw.
- Aw, she said doggy
style, he said romance.
- Hey, yeah, that's correct what he said.
That is correct.
(laughs)
Oh man, we're having fun.